Magic Mike XXL Magic Mike extra
extra-large Magic Mike extra extra long
we'll go with Magic Mike to this film
once again reunites Channing Tatum's
Magic Mike character the male
entertainer as they so often refer to
themselves with his other male
entertainer buddies as they go on a road
trip to this convention in which they
are trying to just make some dollar
bills that's really all it's about but
it's really about the camaraderie
amongst these men the conversations they
have about what they do their viewpoints
on their position in life the way they
affect the women they're dancing for and
it's actually a lot deeper than you
might expect similar to the first Magic
Mike which was directed by Steven
Soderbergh who I think is one of the
best directors who's ever really got his
hands on a camera before the guy has an
amazing eye for director of photography
and although he's not directing this
movie he did return as a director of
photography on Magic Mike - and this is
a gorgeous looking movie and I mean that
in all sincerity this is a beautifully
shot film with excellent cinematography
and lighting and I really do mean that
similar to the first film this is not
the MTV movie that the trailers are
trying to make you think it is and it
was disappointing to see the McConaughey
wasn't returning for this movie but in
his place as MC is yadah Pinkett Smith
and she's great as well
I've made a lot of observations about
the Magic Mike release in my head
because I just like to think deep about
the male stripper movies I guess
something about these movies are very
interesting to me number one the first
one a lot of girls are really excited
about seeing it trust me when I saw the
first Magic Mike at a screening I swear
they were probably like 5 to 10 dudes in
a theater filled with like two to three
hundred people and there were lots of
moans and lots of oohs and ahhs and
cheering and sweating and wet seats but
the strange thing was is that a lot of
women were really disappointed with that
movie because the trailers marketed it
like it was step-up 5 for adults or
something it was actually a movie that
explored the people's lives explored
things about what they do got deep into
the hardships of what it's like to live
that type of lifestyle it was a lot more
serious than people were expecting so
I've actually talked to more men who
like Magic Mike than women which is
really interesting and just like the
first
when this movie ended I saw it with my
wife the two girls behind us were like
man I wish there was more dancing there
wasn't enough Channing Tatum but and we
were like I actually thought it was good
and they just started laughing and they
were like I was like I'm serious I
actually thought it was a pretty good
movie and they were like really you
liked it I swear I was probably the only
guy in the theater tonight - there's
something about these movies that brings
in a certain crowd but then it's
deceptive because it's actually a well
filmed well shot and interesting movie
with characters yes there are actual
characters in this movie they really
flesh them out you see a lot of their
flesh and they flesh them out stripper
jokes yay the movie takes a lot of time
to have people just in cars discussing
their lives discussing their ideas for
new routines talking about themselves
talking about what they're dealing with
that's led them to this place why aren't
they doing exactly what they want to do
why is this the thing that they need to
make money to do what they actually want
to do what do these guys want to do with
their lives also something about this
movie that I think appeals to guys is
something to talk a lot about in this
film the idea of being everything this
person you're dancing for in this moment
needs everything this woman needs right
now you can give that to her and she
loves you for you're just rocking her
socks off you're making her whole day
and I can't really think of any guy who
wouldn't want to have the bodies that
these guys have and the ability to be
able to do that for a woman because I
love the idea of that the fact that
these people these guys are dancing for
you're just making their whole world in
that moment and I think the film
explores the strange beauty of that like
I know I'm getting super philosophical
about the male stripper dicks swinging
around movie but the movie actually goes
in that direction and I was legitimately
impressed I'm not going to look at this
movie and be like oh it's dudes dancing
this is probably horrible it's actually
a really well shot well acted movie with
some legitimately good humor there is a
fantastic gas station scene involving a
Backstreet Boy song that was freakin
hilarious
there are times though in the movie
tries to reach a little bit for some
emotion that just isn't there because
you have to meet
certain requirements with a movie like
this you have to have stripper routines
every here and there and they have to be
big and they have to be loud and have to
be awesome but the movie is also trying
to do more than that and there are some
times where those two different themes
clash a lot because they work as
routines these guys are talented as hell
but then when they're trying to go for
some of the more emotional elements they
don't always form a cohesive whole also
any movie about male strippers that has
the balls no pun intended to make fun of
Twilight I gotta give that some major
props I'm gonna give Magic Mike to a be
real talk here guys I just watched a
bunch of dudes with their asses hanging
out and and I liked it I enjoyed
the film what can I say
guys I'm curious to know what you
thought of this film or the last film
because I find the whole Magic Mike
thing very interesting because it
attracts a certain crowd and then
sometimes that crowd isn't pleased for
some reason because it actually goes
deeper than they were expecting I want
to know what your guys thoughts on that
are guys I also want to let you know
that I'm still doing my promotion with
crunchyroll.com it's an anime streaming
service I'm offering my viewers 30 days
of it for free if you go to
crunchyroll.com slash Chris Stockman you
can take advantage of this awesome
service from people who love and care
about anime streaming an HD with no ads
you're getting shows directly from Japan
sometimes hours after they premiere in
Japan with English subtitles you can't
get that experience anywhere and I'm
always trying to look for promotions
that I can do for you guys that give you
stuff because you guys are the best free
stuff I want to give you guys free stuff
as often as I can they have so many
great shows like attack on Titan which I
will be talking about soon I hope you
guys check it out that's crunchyroll.com
slash Chris Duckman thanks guys and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes